we all know that cardiac diseases are a
wolf and a big you know it's like they
are they're hemorging as an epidemic I
mean the world is dealing with cardiac
diseases
and since uh ECG is a four stage this is
going to be a revolutionary product
because it is going to help everyone
around the world
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
talking to Neha rastogi the founder and
CEO of Agata an entrepreneur with over a
decade of experience in creating
affordable and technologically advanced
Healthcare products she possesses great
leadership skills along with being the
founder of the company she has also
built the Prototype of its Flagship
product the scientific life ECG monitor
she has won various prestigious Awards
woman entrepreneur award By Thai digital
women award by she the people TV by
rectai winner award for women and
entrepreneurial research in the field of
biotechnology and Aegis Graham award
please meet Neha
fantastic great well Neha and you know
tell me a little bit about yourself
you're working in the medical devices
space you know in ECG you're the founder
of a medical devices company startup
um and so tell me a little bit about
your story and about you know what
excites you and what what led you to to
be in this space
so uh Michael I'm an electronics and
telecomplication in general and I was
working in an MNC was a regular job uh
when my father-in-law was detected with
a guardian disease and he was good on
medications and uh you know the doctors
suggested that he would have to go for
regular checkups every now and then you
know to ensure that there's no uh the
digital heart attack or there's no
arrests of you know or severe problems
so uh since uh you know you must be
doing anything even worldwide uh you
know parents are a little bit separately
and you know uh there's nobody to look
after them and same for the case with us
and um we just thought about you know
having a tool which can monitor cardiac
diseases and which anybody can use it
out there any I any place and you know
if you use it gather the data about that
and or transmit it to the doctor to get
uh you know instant or advice or instant
treatments
so we just uh researched and there were
no products or no devices or tools
available and we thought that you know
if we you know we being uh me and man
husband both of us being dropping the
joining's background not buying on
create a miniature ECG device and
ucg is something which has to be taken
which is a gold standard which uh which
is the first test which a doctor
suggests to get any information about
art so he didn't
um you know we didn't start with an
intention of starting a medical device
and startup per se we just wanted wanted
a tool to help our father and uh in just
eventually so happened that you know
once we get a quarter prototype showed
it to the doctors the doctors were so
enthusiastic about it uh they encouraged
it a lot
um and you know they they even gave us
not a valuable feedback like how to make
it more valuable for the users as well
as for the doctors and that's all you
know after three years of r d and uh
reiterations and you know redesigning
and everything we came up with the first
product which is like which is a 4K ECG
device uh and it takes you to do just by
thoughts so just by Touch of or you know
a touch of the sensors you can take your
ECG uh go and get a report on your
smartphone uh it can be you know shared
digitally or it can be printed it can be
shown to the doctor and instant uh you
know remote or actually remote uh
treatment can be found I mean remote
advice can be taken and um instant
action can be taken so this device is
actually really helping people in case
you know where people feel symptoms like
chest pain or shortness of breath or you
know some kind of uneasiness in their
heart or body and they they get confused
whether it's a hard problem or is it
something else
comes very handy it's a very you know it
took me science
so it can be candid anywhere and it's
completely wireless so no why he was
doing really eats nothing has to wear
Dash to the body even with Own It
communicates wirelessly it's battery
operated so no power uh is required so
it's completely you know hassle free and
anybody can take it out use a capture
their heart data and you don't create a
report and share with the doctor
incredible tell me a little bit about
ECG the and and the meaning you
mentioned sort of the personal story but
tell me a little bit more on a global
scale the impact of yeah you know it's
such a device or or the or I should say
the accessibility to such a device in
the world well what what opportunities
does that create what problems does it
solve on honest scale
right so as I said CJ is the fourth
stage which you know anywhere in the
world so go and standard uh it's it is
done as a first stage to detect any
property with the card now if you have
seen ECG tradition ECG machine selling
beating machines which I came to the
hospitals and all those wires coming out
of uh the machine which are attacked at
different points of the body and then
the data is captured you know electric
voltage is capture and it is shown in a
graphical format or the monitor
so what we have done is we have
miniaturized the whole setup so you know
the big machine is now a cartoon chain
size machine the wires have been
replaced at a sensor so that instead of
placing the wires of the body it uh
actually you know you just need to touch
the sensors at different parts of the
body and the monitor is replaced by a
smartphone so all the processing and
everything has been or you know it's
being done be smartphone and um you know
remotely can reach to doctor anywhere in
the world so so you know this is the
first of its kind device in the world
which can capture reads of easy tree
just by touch so completely wireless
heat press painless you know
non-invasive device and you know anybody
can take uh his uh EC Jeep in a sitting
position and you know really doesn't
have to like uh no it's right procedure
has to be uh you know uh
so uh definitely you know we all know
that cardiac diseases are a wolf and a
big you know it's like they are they're
hemorging as an epidemic I mean the
world is dealing with cardiac diseases
and since uh ECG is the first test this
is going to be a revolutionary product
because it is going to help everyone
around the world
what does it mean so what are the
different things that you have to to
optimize for as you're making it
accessible for people around the world
so you were I heard you're making a lot
of emphasis before on the sort of the
the portability of the product to the
ease of use what did you find you know
through your understanding of the
consumer market and what people need
what what it what needs to happen so
that this is you know making a high
impact on on individuals around the
world using it
see first of all uh worldwide the ECG
devices are completely
um not connected uh you know uh they
they give out paper reports and uh paper
reports
um you know they just get lost and
Diesel pack data wants to speak then
what was the reason uh you know last
month or last year or you know 10 years
back he has to go through all those big
fines of reports and everything so we
have digitize everything so that is the
first because we get
um the impact that some gate life is
going to create that everything is
digital secondly uh you know uh since
the ECG process was so compulsive with
all those wires being attached and
everything just touch base ECG and that
to a medical grade agency which the
doctors can believe the doctors can
actually gather some information and you
know uh they can uh detect a problem
with
the first time and you know it is said
in the first time it's a great life so
just by touch uh the ECG is sorted and
within five minutes no no uh you know
not more than that
right third is obviously you know the
portability Factor because and the
connectivity Factor because you know uh
born by then station countries like
India where population is huge uh you
know not everyone is able to reach the
best Healthcare facilities and there are
so many countries like this and you know
uh in cases of heart attack time is of
essence and when a person actually feels
or experiences any heart attack or any
problem in heart
um he has to reach to a doctor
immediately
so instead of running to a doctor and
you know in case of false alarms that
any of uh you know the non-trivial
issues a person can use this device and
can you know send the report to the
doctor and doctor can actually make some
contribution out of it and you know he
can advise the best so be another three
most important and the biggest uh
impactful uh factors it's against uh
Bracken to bowling
well what are some of the challenges
that you expect for a company like this
as you're growing it what what what are
the main things that you think are going
to be the most I guess difficult or or
interesting that you'll have to overcome
see challenges on many firstly
um Health itself is a very challenging
uh domain it is you know you cannot just
play around it or you have to be very
accurate you have to have but you know
uh the data which is which you're
capturing and you are showing to the
doctor in class should be very accurate
so that's the reason you know we took
good three three and a half news it's
just r d and just uh making the product
accurate so as to you know make everyone
believe in it secondly uh you know uh
since uh there are regulatory uh you
know implications and there are a lot of
regulatory barriers that you have to uh
cross uh to meet the product available
and you know to make the products
scannable to make the product reach to
the masses it really requires a lot of
time and energy and efforts and of
course you know um because uh we have we
are doing we are constantly doing our
trials our validations and you know
certifications and regulations
um now people have started believing in
the product and now we're exporting uh
them outside India also so yeah so you
know challenges many can of course uh
Finance funding and you know these
challenges are always there with any
startup especially with a product
startup which will have you know a lot
of uh a lot of capabilitative uh r d
which uh we have to do so yeah
foreign
interesting and so from a trust point of
view
how do you get the public to trust sort
of this you know maybe this is more even
more of a general question for the
medical devices space but what are some
of the ways in which you can Garner
trust from you know the average
consumers in um you know using a product
trusting the information trusting who
stores that information and and this and
the authenticity of it how do you how do
you think through those issues
yeah so like actually this is a very uh
interesting question and it will be
always always done it with this when we
were building the product because we
wanted uh this product nor is it you
know we didn't want to project it as a
ECG device we wanted to project it as a
tool to monitor cardiac problems uh
which anybody can do X and we always
dealt with this question that you know
better people who trusted or not how
people who trust it and maybe you know
to our surprise when we actually brought
a product in Market uh it was in doctors
who trusted it more and they started uh
purchasing it uh you know using it and
recommended recommending it to their
patient and that is uh doctors are the
biggest tree photos they are the biggest
uh you know validators that yeah this is
a device which means business this is
not some you know uh brand of the bill
kind of Prana so um so that very one way
good uh you know response from the
medical fraternity from Healthcare
professionals and they started buying
all the product for themselves and for
their even for you know using it at in
their own clinics or in their own
offices uh to screen the patient quickly
you know because and not everyone can
afford those big infrastructure big
machines and then you know obviously
when if a doctor trusts it the patients
in the masses start were addressing the
product so uh so that's how you know the
trust is being created
all right
no no that makes a lot of sense and now
that that really does make a lot of
sense now if you're looking at sort of
your own journey and you started talking
a little bit about the personal sort of
connection to this if we're looking back
into how this you know is uh relevant
for you tell me a little bit about you
as an entrepreneur well what do you care
about what gets you really excited about
this journey and about what what are you
doing here
yeah so you know when whenever we look
behind whenever we look at our journey
we always think of one day it always
started with uh you know uh with a
personal problem we wanted to create a
tool for our father we wanted to save
his life uh we didn't want him to go
through anything and you know certain
um problem and uh you know and he being
far but today that tool is saving so
many lives and that is what actually
creates you know excitemented us and
that is what keeps us going you know so
you talked about challenges so you know
every day is a new challenge every day
is a new problem when we keep going
because we know that this has the power
of saving lives and that is where uh you
know the impact of the joy you know the
the actual meaning of this whole uh the
idea nice uh and you know now that is
what uh uh you know me believing
so so what would you know in your for
your case what would be a victory or
what what would Mark the success of of
this company how would you define
success
but there's no particular definition of
success I think of you know we are
getting successful with each passing day
because you know we are getting uh to
see how people are getting the product
out how differently they're using so you
know right now in India even the Army
Personnel like using it in the most uh
you know remotest areas or you know
where they are posted even even the uh
national gas and uh cool and binders are
using our product in the minds uh for
you know it cases a hard problem what is
a problem you know for the people down
there
um there are so many remotest areas
underprivileged areas where the product
is being used for quick screening and
wink or monitoring of weak detection of
art so I think um this small small phase
is what defines success for us uh we
haven't since we never started similar
idea of having the startup or creating a
unicorn or you know getting a big and
famous so we we never see startup we'd
never see success right in those terms
so we are just taking small steps and uh
yeah and I think we're reaching there
and the success would mean that you know
uh like a thermometer every household
should have this device and uh you know
nobody should die because there was a
delay in reaching hospital where
something bad happened to the god
yeah well I think it's just an awesome
uh a great example both of a you know
personal personal motivation you know a
deeper understanding of the market and
the different opportunities and it
sounds like you're
you really are supplying people that
really are in need of such such devices
with sort of innovation and tools to do
that and it sounds like you're putting a
lot of emphasis on the portability of it
on the the accessibility of it and which
sounds like this is you know sort of the
the real bread and butter of of how to
of how to make meaning here and and you
mentioned quite a few times that this is
just the start so I'm looking forward to
to cheering from the side and continuing
to following your great work and I
really appreciate your your time and
your energy and thank you very much for
the inspiration Neha and best of luck
great great interacting with you Michael
thank you
[Music]